- [Narrator] This is indigo.
Real indigo.
Jeans, they're dyed from a chemical.
But real indigo straight
from the plant has its roots
in Samurai culture and is
highly prized in Japan.
Yep, this story is all
about the real color blue.
But it's not as dull as it sounds.
Tokushima, Japan is located in
the southwest of the country
and for centuries, it has
been known for its indigo
due to the Yoshino-gawa
River, which flows underground
warming the soil.
Indigo started gaining
popularity in the early 1600s
and was commonly used by Samurais.
This is Osamu Nii.
He's a sixth generation
indigo plant grower.
Real indigo was also used
for firefighters' clothing
because it's flame retardant,
up to 1500 degrees Fahrenheit.
To produce indigo ink, the
leaves must be harvested
and then dried in the sun
and flipped repeatedly
with a broom until they turn a navy hue.
Because of this, Osamu
is one of the last five
indigo growers in the region.
The practice is time-consuming
and labor intensive,
so former growers have turned to
cheaper chemical alternatives.
But the thing is, with real indigo,
the color you can achieve is unparalleled.
This is Toshiharu Furusho.
He's a fabric dyer.
He's able to pull out an
incredible range of blues
from the natural ink.
From a nearly black
blue they call nando-iro
to deep ocean hues called kachi-iro.
Achieving these colors though is not easy.
His commitment to his craft
can be seen in his hands.
His nails are eternally
stained blue from nearly
50 years of working with the dye.
And Osamu, he's not hanging
up his trowel yet either.